how are you John I'm doing great thanks
for having me you bet you bet should we
start with the first question of Chris
Brockman that just got tweeted into the
program from from Lee Janzen yeah why
not is that true two-time US Open
champion Lee Janssen what are you tweet
the program yeah we Jansen wants to know
John if you brought your clubs to Los
Angeles that's an from a two-time US
Open champion John I did not in the
beginning of the postseason the first
couple games are filled with hours and
hours of research and video and then as
the as the as the series prolongs it's a
lot easier to just follow the series so
okay the first three years that's been
my formula after the first couple games
then I bring my club that's your routine
that's your routine I'm here and you're
sticking with the routine okay
it's amazing the two-time US Open
champion Lee Jansen is curious about
whether you brought your clust
to the ALDS John hello by the way okay
fantastic so what did you make it last
night's game John and about the Dodgers
ability to make the World Series again
yeah you know a lot of these
best-of-five is a teeter-totter of
perception right I mean the perception
going in was the the Dodgers are the
favorites coming in based on their
roster based on their experience and all
the different blueprints that they have
to win a baseball game and win a series
and hit and move on well the the Braves
on the other hand were probably you know
most people took him for granted didn't
understand the kind of year they had and
they would have to play a more perfect
game to be able to take down the Dodgers
and unfortunately for the Braves the
Dodgers played a perfect game they did
everything they had to do that is a
strength they pitched fantastic and
controlled the strike zone because the
Braves are really good ahead in the
count first pitch I thought Rouge game
plan was perfect and it showed up and
the stats I thought the Dodgers flexing
their muscles and put pressure on teams
by taking walks and with the long ball
having said that everybody would just
assume okay well the Dodgers are gonna
go on and win this series easily and
Clayton Kershaw oh by the way is
pitching game two but what makes this
series I think so interesting is that it
can turn quickly now by all accounts the
Dodgers have everything they need to do
and I said in the beginning of the year
for whatever it's worth when they ask
you who's gonna represent the National
League I thought it would be the Dodgers
and so as this thing plays out and they
had to kind of scratch and crawl to get
into the postseason they're playing
great baseball right now and the Braves
are going to have to find a way to upset
that kind of momentum that the Dodgers
have currently it just seems to me that
the Dodgers getting what they needed to
get from Muncie and joc pederson and
obviously Justin Turner doing his thing
he can earn an Dez it just strikes me
that if and I think when Manny Machado
just goes Machado and starts maybe
taking one game over himself
this team is is is a potential
juggernaut that could take down whoever
comes out of the American League John is
that fair to say it is it is fair to say
and then absolutely it's been the most
balanced and some people would say it's
weaker I don't think it's weaker it's
just more balanced where there's an
American League has four just well five
great teams four that represent them now
and and I think for the Dodgers the
formula last year was driven by numbers
it was driven by you know this is what
you're gonna do analytically this is how
we're going to win a game and it almost
worked you know they got to one game
from winning the World Series this year
I don't think they can follow the
numbers I think this year they have to
deviate a little bit and follow the eyes
of the starting pitchers that they have
on this staff that are so good that can
get them deeper into the game and not
expose the bullpen as much this year and
I think that's going to be the formula
you saw it last night been comfortable
leads seven innings out of Ryu Clayton
Kershaw is not going to go 9 anymore but
7 is going to be great enough for their
team to be successful I just don't think
you can expect the bullpen after four
innings or five innings of a starter to
carry the load and I said going into
this series
for both teams with somewhat of a
question mark in the bullpen of course
the Braves don't have much experience
down there but they've got good arms
whoever has to use the bullpen the most
I do not think will win this series what
do you think of the Rockies Brewers how
good how good can the Brewers be do you
think John
well I still scratch my head a little
bit on Game one I guess they had the
right formula because who can argue to a
the one hit through eight innings using
their bullpen even though Woodruff
eventually I think it's going to be a
starter for them
III just got to believe that if that's
going to be the formula throughout the
postseason and they're able to get to
the World Series doing that kind of
stuff then I tip my hat to them I just
don't know if that's possible they're
gonna have to rely on their starters to
give them some innings I know their
bullpen is fantastic it's it's wipeout
but I think they're gonna be wiped out
if nice if they have to eat up that many
innings in the offense that both these
clubs have were shut down quite
exclusively and it's going to be an
interesting story once they get to
Colorado how everybody handles the
situation that way versus it's a lot
easier to hit in Colorado for for the
Rockies their bullpen is outstanding and
you can't really expect them to keep up
at this pace if their offense is going
to have to show that they can they can
muster more runs on the road than they
have in the last 11 or you know last two
weeks so exciting game I didn't get a
chance to see much of it but saw some
highlights and and certainly the most
the team that everybody looks at with
kind of caution to the whim that they
don't really want to get caught up in it
is the Milwaukee Brewers they don't want
to get caught up in a in a 5 inning game
and again I say that with the fact that
if they have to do this every series I
don't know how how it plays out
long-term baseball hall-of-famer John
Smoltz here on the Rich Eisen show walk
me through what we should be looking for
out of Chris Sale tonight to know that
he's okay and game 1 against the Yankees
yeah that's a great question I've never
been in a situation quite like what
Chris Sale is dealing with as far as the
the down the stretch and the lack of
innings we all know how nasty is we know
how can dominate a game and unfairly for
it
at 108 games there's no advantage that
they have I've always said this I've
continued to say this you 108 games
you're the best team in baseball and you
only have to play the team that had to
play one game coming in in the end the
Yankees or in this case in the in this
case the Yankees or could have been the
ACE I just think the the sediments going
to be Chris Sale is going to have to be
really really good and that's going to
Swift the teeter-totter back to the
Boston Red Sox a lot of people feel and
and rightfully so is the Yankees of 100
games they're healthy their lineup is
just chugging and you're talking about
Chris Sale David Price Purcell Oh or
even a Rodriguez three left-handers that
they may have to face and everybody
talks about the Boston bullpen
well the Boston bullpen is not even
gonna come into play if those starters
keep doing what they're supposed to be
doing or have done so a lot of pressure
on Chris Sale a lot of eyes going to be
on the radar gun I'm not so consumed
with that as much as can he have his
touch pizzas and command and more
importantly will he be able to bounce
back you know from the rest of the time
he's had from the DL to you know the
adrenaline rush of the postseason
against your arch rivals so it's going
to be phenomenal series but allies are
gonna be on Chris Sale for sure yeah
what do you think's going on between the
temples of Red Sox and Yankees right now
on the day of their first playoff series
in 14 years first between these two long
rivals and it's a bunch of young kids
here okay so it's not like that they go
way back 15 20 years to even the 2004
series the last time these two teams
faced each other but it's the first time
these franchises come in with triple
digits of regular-season wins it's
really amazing I'm wondering what you
think's going on between the temples
there John yeah it's interesting in the
regular season you know been around both
teams and the Yankees at times you know
they have their stress that we're
dominant and then they really didn't
have a healthy lineup for the longest
time and no player will ever say this
but during the regular season you tip
your hat there were a better team
meaning the Red Sox they just they were
but then once you see the momentum
coming back from the Yankees getting
healthy getting judged back in some of
their parts back and making the moves
they did you could see why this was
must-see TV coming forward in the class
that everyone wanted to see and you know
the red side is confident and rightfully
so offensively they're as good as it
gets its top-heavy their offense relies
on their first five guys no doubt their
defense is fantastic and they're
starting pitching is fantastic whereas
the Yankees have such a long lineup and
it has so much stress to put on the
right you know the starting pitcher and
for that matter anyone who has to go
through that lineup that's where they
get you they fatigue you to death you
know and then they run into some home
runs so I I really believe I know this
is gonna sound crazy but you know the
game has changed in so many different
ways that we're watching more home runs
walks and strikeouts but I think it's
going to be the team that could put the
ball in play it the most opportunistic
times because there's a lot of
strikeouts in the Yankees lineup and if
they're young players which by the way
and you are and Andujar and Torres are
two of their better hitters and they're
they're rookies that if the Red Sox and
Yankees ultimately this thing could be
swung on who puts the ball and play more
than the other team and I know that
sounds like oh my gosh what are you
talking about Smoltz this isn't the
1920s but this is what we have and
playoff baseball is usually won that way
you look at the Astros and what they did
you look at even with the Chicago Cubs
we're able to do the Kansas City Royals
the teams that usually get to the end
are the ones that fundamentally play the
game at the time they need it the best
now you could make a case to a couple
minutes I have left with you John Smoltz
that the defending World Series champs
are far better this time around than
they were last year I mean the way that
Bregman is playing right now is lights
out he's there you could say he's their
best player on a team filled with stars
from Altuve to everyone else right and
then Verlander is getting the ball
tonight but then the Cleveland Indians
you could make a case are better than
the team that might have knocked off the
Yankees last year I mean it's it's
amazing how loaded this American League
is right now how do you think Indians
Astros plays out you know again nobody's
talking about at least at the level that
they should be talking about the Indians
so they're in a great spot I mean think
about they won their division easy they
weren't pressed their starting rotation
took a little bit of it took a big hit
actually would bother not being able to
finish the year the way he was counted
on because he's been fantastic this year
the two best starting rotations and
baseball gonna go at against each other
and that's leaving out really the Boston
Red Sox who are just equally as good
when you think about what they thrown
out so this really is a throwback series
to where you're gonna see the Terry
Francona AJ hints rely heavily on their
starters now to your point the Astros
are much better their bullpens much
better perception of their pen is better
and of course they added a monster to
their rotation so they're well equipped
but the road to the World Series this
year for them I think is that much more
difficult so it really is a class of the
Titans of this and look I I'm I'm not
stuck in old school baseball but I would
love to watch these guys go at it
because when you go to a baseball game
with Houston and Cleveland you're not
going to the baseball game watching 12
pitchers per game pace you're going to
the baseball game watching classic old
style get after it yeah true starters
that we've gotten away from as an
industry and that's why there's someone
that's why we're talking about him in
the realm that we are I love it yes John
the poll question before we send him out
the door Chris go for it okay John which
American League team has the best chance
to win the World Series of course
Indians Astros Red Sox Yankee what do
you have for me you know it's hard to go
against Houston and their pedigree of
what they've been through and and and
look it's still thankfully my life
doesn't depend on making that pick it
would be the our hardest pick to pick
because L for those teams are equally as
competent to make the run so it's much
like matchups in the NCAA tournament
sometimes you get a good seed and you
get an opportunity to go through well
all four of them got bad seeds because
they have to play really really good
teams but if you pressed me I'd say it
is still Houston defending champ
someone's got to knock them off all
right John appreciate it thanks for the
call I really really do so do you use
rental clubs later on in the postseason
would you ever do so you know I have and
and honestly you find some gems
sometimes and I write down the
information and actually utilize that
yes so I will I
will not shy away from using Rena clubs
I will bring my own shoes okay that's
what I was about to say cuz you know I
know some people that will refuse
bowlers refuse to use anybody elses ball
and certainly anybody else's shoes when
they go on the road okay just trying to
figure on love that you'd love the call
as always whenever you're on it and I
appreciate the call here well chat soon
thank you better that's John Smoltz
baseball hall-of-famer the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience